اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه مفصله
نخصص معظمها لمتابعه التطورات المشهد في
السودان لكن البدايه بالعناوي
هدوء حدث في العاصمه السودانيه بعد ساعات
من دخول الهدنه السادسه حيز التنفيذ
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يحذر من ازمه صحيه
بسبب انتشار جثامين قتل الاشتباكات
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه استانفوا انشطته
في السودان ويحذر من انتشار الجوع في
البلاد
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
روسيا تقصف ب 18 صاروخا والانفجارات تهز
مدينتي
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اعلن طرفان في السودان موافقتهما
على اتفاق هدنه جديد للاغراض الانسانيه
لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه يبقى عدم
خرق هذه الهدنه كسابقتها اختبارا حقيقيا
على جديه الطرفين في تجاوز الازمه الراهنه
وفي ضوء الازمه الانسانيه الاخذه بالتدهور
بسرعه في السودان حتى المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده طرفيه الصراع في
السودان على حمايه المدنيين والبنى
التحتيه والسماحي بممر امن للفرينه من
مناطق القتال وتسهيل عمليات الاغاثه
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعت المرسى
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه مثل التنبات
ومناطق المجاوره
مباشره من النيل
من النيل ومن هنا من المرسى وانت ماشي
بتعاني جدعاني شديد جدعاني تتحرك
[موسيقى]
مع دخول الهدنه الجديده حيز التنفيذ
يسودوا هدوء حذر في السودان فيما نشر
الجيش السوداني لقطات لقائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان وهو يشرف على سير العمليات
العسكريه من احد مراكز القياده
[موسيقى]
وكان الجيش السوداني وافق على تمديد
الهدنه لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه معلنا ان
الموقف العمليات مستقر في الخرطوم والوضع
هادئ في جميع الولايات وذلك بعد موافقه
على التمديد الهدنه مع قوه الدعم السريع
لكن الجيش اضافه بانه رصد تحركات لدعم
السريع في خارج العاصمه لتعزيز موقفه على
الارض مؤكدا جاهزيه الجيش لصدي اي محاوله
للهجوم
السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
بفوتوفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير ومتغير الاخير الذي تمصل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست لا
ليس ليس صحيحا
قبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع الموافقه
على التمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لاثنتين 72
ساعه بما يسمح بفتح الممرات الانسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين والمقيمين وجددت
قوات الدعم السريع في بيان النشرته على
صفحتها الرسميه في تويتر التزامها الذي
وصفته بالصارم بالهدنه الانسانيه والوقف
الكامل لاطلاق النار وقالت انها تصدت
لهجمات متكرره من الجيش خلال ايام الهدنه
من جانبه قال رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب
الامه القوميه السودانيه مصباح احمد ان
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه جاءت مفصله
واضاف في تصريحات العربيه بان مبادره
تتضمن ثلاثه مراحل مهمه لوقف النار
والانتهاء بعمليه سياسيه تفضي الى تاسيس
حكم مدني
ما هو مهم في هذه المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه انها جاءت مفصله برؤيه هذه
الرؤيه تحمل ثلاثه مراحل المرحله الاولى
هي مرحله الحوار حول وقف اطلاق النار
وتحديد اليات المراقبه ثم الانتقال الى
الحوار حول القضايا العالقه التي تنهي
الخلاف وتنتقل بنا الى
معالجه النقاط الخلاف وفقا لما وتوقف في
العمليه السياسيه بدمج القوات الدم
الدعم الشريف في القوات المسلحه
واستكمال هذه الترتيبات ثم الانتقال الى
مرحله العموديه السياسيه
التي تاسيس الحكم المدني
وخروج المواصلات العسكريه بالكامل عن
معادله الحكم والسياسي نسعى مبدئيا الان
الهم الاساسي بالنسبه لنا هو ان توقف هذه
الحرب اولا
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك استاذ عمار على شاشه العربيه
بدايه هل يمكن ان تؤكد لنا اخر التطورات
المدنيه على الارض في الخرطوم وايضا باقي
الولايات من خلال مارستموح
نعم يعني من خلال هذا الصباح كانت هنالك
اشتباكات في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم من عدد في
عدد من المعسكرات التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع كانت هنالك قرارات مثل طيران
الحربي على تلك المناطق وردت عليها مضادات
قوات الدعم السريعه المتواجده على الارض
هذا ما يشير الى ان هنالك اختراق لهذه
الهدنه حتى الان وربما هذه الهدن الكثيره
انها تعلن كثيرا ولكن ما ان تحترمه هو
الشيء القليل في هذه الهدنه الجديده بعد
الهدنه الخامسه والان الهدنه السادسه في
حيز التنفيذ ولكن هنالك خروقات دائما فيها
ايضا كانت هنالك اشتباكات متقطعه في وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم وكانت هناك اشتباكات
متقطعه في مدينه بحري هذا ما رصدناه من
خلال الساعات الفائته بعد دخول الهدنه
الجديده الى حيز التنفيذ الان وانا اقف
معك هنا في الشارع وكثير جدا من المواطنين
ما زالوا يع
نعم يعني هذه الاعمده المتصاعده التي
تشاهدها في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم هي
الاشتباكات متقطعه تم الرصد كثير جدا من
الاخبار وكثير جدا من المسجد المستجدات
على ارض الواقع ومن خلال هذه يعني
الاشتباكات يبدو ان عمليه الالتزام
بالهدنه الان على ارض الواقع يبدو صعبا
ولكن لابد ايضا ان نفسر شكل الهدن التي
يتم الاتفاق عليها هل هي هدى جزئيه ام هدى
غير فعاله بنسبه كبيره ام لمناطق معينه ام
لمرات ممرات انسانيه معينه يتم من خلالها
يعني عدد من الممرات الامنه لكثير جدا من
العالقين ولكثير جدا من الرعايه الاجانب
حتى يتم اخراجهم من تلك المناطق او حتى
اذا سمحت عمار فقط
للخطوط الصوره من خلفك هناك عدد من
المواطنين
نعم هي احد المخابز في شارع الستين وقفوا
منذ الصباح الباكر هنا
للاصطفاف حول هذا المخبز الذي ما زال يقدم
هذه الخدمات للمواطنين ومن خلال يصطفون
لساعات طويله جدا يعني تحدثنا الى احدهم
قبل قليل قال بانه يعني للساعه ربما
الثالثه منذ يعني منذ ثلاث ساعات يقف هنا
ويحاول ان
ياخذ ما يحتاجه من الخبز من خلال هذا
المخبز الذي هو ربما الثاني او الوحيد
الذي يعمل في هذه المنطقه يعني هذه الصفوف
ونلاحظ ايضا كذلك بان هذه الصفوف قد
انتظمت وما زالت يعني كثير جدا من الطلبات
الان على هذا المخبز ترد بعد ان تم اعلان
انه يعمل ولو بشكل
انت اين تتحدث ايضا الى اي جزء من
العاملين عمار نعم
نحن في شارع الستين في الشرق العاصمه
الخرطوم
وهذا الشارع كان حيويا جدا كان يعمل طوال
الليل وطوال النهار ومن خلاله الازدحام
الكبير ومن خلاله عدد من المحاله التجاريه
والتي نشاهد ان جميع هذه المحلات او اغلب
هذه المحلات لا تعمل بشكل كلي ربما تعمل
لنصف ساعه او لساعات معينه ومن ثم تعود
هذه المخابز ايضا تعمل لساعات معينه من
استطاع ان ياخذ عدد من يعني حاجياته منه
يمكن ان يذهب بها ومن لم يستطيع اذا كان
بالامكان تحريك الصوره الكاميرا لكي نشاهد
باقي شارع الستين هذا الشارع الحيوي الذي
كان كما تحدثت وتحدثت عدد من الصحافيين
ومراسلين العربيه دائما كان يعج بالحياه
الى مدى هناك حركه هناك ربما حاله اطمئنان
تسود وربما تتاح فسحه للمواطنين للتحرك في
ظل هذا الهدوء الحذر الذي ربما يغل ف
العاصمه السودانيه نشاهد يعني بالصوره عدد
مواطنين يتحركون لكن ماذا عن باقي المحال
التجاريه هل كلها مغلقه هل هناك مناطق
اخرى بها محل مفتوحه
يعني تشاهد من خلال الصوره
ان عدد من المحلات التجاريه ربما يمكن ان
يعمل ولكن ولو بشكل جزئي يعني او حتى ان
تاخذ رقم الهاتف لعدد من المحاله التجاريه
التي ما زالت فيها عدد من البضائع يمكن ان
تاخذ منها ارقام هواتف وتتصل ومن ثم تاخذ
ما تحتاج اليه نلاحظ من خلال الصوره
الحركه ليست بالشكل اللي كان معتاد او
الكان في هذا المكان وربما لعده محاذير
ولعده تخوفات في هذه المنطقه من خلال انها
ربما تجري من حولها عدد من الاشتباكات
العسكريه هل هل شهد هذا الشارع في
السابقا ام مواجهات بين الفاصلين ام انه
كان هادئا ايضا
يعني شهد عدد من الاشتباكات في الايام
الاولى هذا الشارع وهو شارع حيوي ورئيسي
ويربط ما بين شرق الخرطوم ويعني الجانب
الجنوبي من من الجهه الجنوبيه وبه ايضا
موقف للبساطه السفريه التي تنقل عدد كبير
جدا من المواطنين الذين ارادوا الخروج الى
مناطق اكثر امنا الخاصه باتجاه ولايه
الجزيره والولايات الشرقيه بشكل واضح هل
هناك مازال حركه نزوح داخل السودان شاهدنا
قبل قليل في الصوره حافله ربما تتحرك
وتتجه في الاتجاه الاخر هل هذه الحافله
ضمن الحافلات التي تقوم بنقل من يريد
مغادره الخرطوم
يعني عدد من الحافلات الان تتجه في هذه
المناطق وتخرج من هذه المناطق للمناطق
الشرقيه ولي عدد من المناطق القريبه من
هذا المكان وهذه يعني المناطق ايضا تاثرت
بشكل واضح وكبير من خلال الازمات الكثيره
جدا التي احاطت بهذه المنطقه هنالك محل
تجاريه كبيره جدا في هذه المنطقه تاثرت
بفعل ايضا عمليات السلب والنهب وبفعل
العديد من العمليات التي اثرت في حركه
المواطن وحركه التبضع وحركه الشراء وعدد
من المستشفيات ايضا في هذه الطريق قد
توقفت بشكل كبير واصبحت لا تستطيع ان تقدم
الخدمات بالنسبه للاسعار المواد الغذائيه
من بينها الخبز هل ما زالت على حالها ام
شهدت ارتفاعا
يعني الاسعار تشهد ارتفاعا ملحوضا يعاني
اصحاب المخابز في الحصول على حصص الدقيق
ويعاني ايضا كذلك في توفير البيئه والمكان
للعاملين لديه ويعاني ايضا كذلك من قطوعات
الكهرباء وعدم توفر الغاز لذلك يضطر الى
رفع عدد من الاسعار هنالك شكاوى كثيره جدا
الان من المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
وباعتبار انه المخبز الذي يعمل وهنا ربما
رفع الاسعار بشكل واضح ومباشر ومن خلال
هكذا يعني النقاط يستشعر المواطن الوضع من
حوله ويرى بانه في غايه الصعوبه حينما
ترتفع الاسعار ولا تثبت على سعر معين يعني
هذا السعر الذي يقدم اليوم لا يكون
السعر الذي سيقدم بالغد
وهل هناك رقابه على اسعار الخبز مثلا
والمواد الاساسيه ام ان اسعارها محرره لا
تخضع لاي تسير
لم اسمعكم جيدا هل اسعار الخبز والمواد
الاساسيه
مراقبه ومثبته من الحكومه ام انها حره
يعني تخضع لقانون العرض والطلب
يعني هذه الاسعار واضح من خلال الوضع الذي
نحن فيه بانها لا تخضع للمراقبه هنالك عدد
من الولايات في السودان ربما فعلت قوانين
كثيره جدا بحكم ازمه المحروقات وازمه
الخبز وعدد من الازمات ولكن هنا باعتبارنا
الاشتباكات ما زالت دائره وضعيه الحرب ما
زالت مفعله فيصعب عمليه ضبط هذه الاسعار
بشكل واضح ومن خلال كثير من الجولات
الميدانيه تختلف اسعار من منطقه الى منطقه
ومن مكان الى مكان فيما يتعلق بانتشار
الامني هل رصدتم انتشارا امنيا كان هناك
حديث وشاهدنا صور لانتشار القوات الامنيه
هل هناك اي تواجد امني في هذه الجهه التي
تتواجد فيها من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
يعني في المكان الذي نحن فيه لم نرصد اي
اتجاه او اي نشره لعدد من القوات الامنيه
في هذا المكان باعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
ايضا ما زالت تجري فيها عدد من الاشتباكات
وما زالت ربما تحتاج الى كثير جدا من
عمليات الممرات الامنه حتى يتم من خلالها
تجسير عدد من الطرق لعدد من القوات
الامنيه التي تعمل في مثل هكذا الظروف طيب
اذا كان بالامكان فقط ان توجز لنا اخر ما
وصلتكم من انباء حول ربما حصيله
الاشتباكات وايضا ما اذا كان هناك ربما
انباء عن انتشار
جثامين وجثث في شوارع العاصمه هل هناك
جهود شعبيه يقوم بها الناس لمحاوله
السيطره على هذا الموضوع خصوصا بانه بعض
المناطق من الصعب جدا اخلاء هذه الجسامين
نعم يعني هنالك عدد من الاخبار تحدثت
الينا وعدد من المصادر بان هنالك مناطق
استطاعت من خلالها كثير من المبادرات وحتى
بالتشبيك مع عدد من منظمات التي تعمل على
ارض الميدان في انتشال هذه الجثث ودفن
بعضها ولكن هنالك مناطق ما زالت عمليات
الوصول اليها صعبه جدا حتى يتم من خلالها
انتشال الجثث ورفعها مره
تلو المره من تلك المناطق وهذا يبدو صعبا
من خلال
الشهادات التي رايناها وكثير جدا
لدينا اذا مشكله في وصول الصوت والتي من
خلالها ينشر
الصوت يتقطع على كل حال انا اشكرك على كل
هذه المعلومات والصور المباشره التي قمت
بثها لنا عمار ابو شيبه الصحفي كنت معنا
مباشره من الخرطوم
في متابعه الاوضاع الطبيه قال المسؤول
الاعلامي هلال الاحمر السوداني ابو اسامه
ابو بكر في تصريحاتنا العربيه ان
التقديرات تشير لوجود نحو 500 جثه لقتل
الاشتباكات واضاف بان جثامين قتل
الاشتباكات تمثل مشكله كبرى سنحتاج
للمعينات الطبيه بالذات مختلف المعينات
الطبيه والمستلزمات الطبيه والشحنه
القادمه من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
هي فيها كل المستلزمات الطبيه حسب
الاولويات المطروحه بحكم انه اللجنه
الدوليه
قائمه منذ عشرات السنين في السودان ونعمل
مع بعض سويا لذلك كل الاشياء الجايه في
الشحنه دي هي اشياء عندها اولويه طبعا
الشحنه يعني
هي ثمانيه طن او 8000 كيلو يعني وبالتالي
حتحدث انفراج كبير جدا
ابو بكر قال ايضا للعربيه انا مساعدات
الطبيه المرسله من الصليب الاحمر تمثل
انفرادجه كبيره للازمه الصحيه في السودان
التي تاثرت بشكل كبير بسبب الاقتتال
الدائر بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
للمساعدات من برنامج الغذاء العالمي او اي
من المؤسسات العالميه اكيد حتستفيد منها
المواطنين وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما
نحن عندنا الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده وغيرها في انه هي
بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على متطوعين متخصصين
في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ عددهم النصف مليون
متطوع عن حق السودان
من جانبه اكل مدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه احمد المنظري انه واحدا وستين
بالمائه من المؤسسات الصحيه في الخرطوم لا
تعمل بسبب الهجمات العسكريه المباشره كما
اوضح ان هناك 23% من مستشفيات الخرطوم
تعمل بنصف طاقتها بينما تعمل سته عشر
بالمئه فقط من المستشفيات بكامله طاقتها
61% من المؤسسات الصحيه العامله في
الخرطوم لا تعمل توقفت عن العمل للاسباب
التي ذكرتها بالاضافه الى الهجمات
العسكريه المباشره والاحتلال العسكري لهذه
المؤسسات وطرد العاملين منها
23% من هذه المستشفيات في الخرطوم تعمل
بشكل جزئي
16% فقط تعمل بكامل طاقتها فهذا هو وضع
المؤسسات الصحيه والنظام الصحي في عموم
السودان ولكن بالاخص في المناطق التي فيها
نزاعات وبلغات الارقام طبعا هناك ما يقارب
من 16 مليون
مواطن سوداني اي ما يمثل ثلث سكان السودان
تحت ما يسمى بالمعونات الانسانيه والتي
للاسف يعني سوف تتوقف بصعوبه النزاعات
الحاصل حاليا في السودان
المنظري قال ايضا ان هناك ضعفا حقيقيا
ومخيفا جدا في النظام الصحي بالسودان لا
سيما نقص التمويل الطبي والامدادات الطبيه
بسبب انعدام الامن وصعوبه الوصول
للمستشفيات هناك فعلا يعني نقص حقيقي في
الكادر الطبي وخصوصا بعد ظهور هذه الازمه
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين يعني هناك نقص في
الكادر الطبي وخصوصا الكادر الطبي المتخصص
على سبيل المثال في الجراحه وفي التقدير
هناك نقص في التمويل
الطبي والامدادات الطبيه والمستلزمات
الطبيه خلال هذه الايام بسبب انعدام الامن
وصعوبه الوصول الى المستشفيات هناك نقص في
توفر بعد بعض المستلزمات الاساسيه على
سبيل المثال
الدم ومشتقاته هناك نقص في امدادات
الاكسجين هناك انقطاع متكرر للكهرباء
وكذلك يعني نقص في امدادات المياه نق ص في
الوقود نقص في امدادات التغذيه للمرضى
والمقيمين في هذه المستشفيات
معنا تفاقم الازمه الصحيه في السودان زادت
المخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير الدواء
مع دخول اشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغه هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليه نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في
الحايل الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفر في
الظروف العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت
اكبر تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار
والصغار على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه
بارتفاع مستمر فيما اصنافها المتوفره
بانخفاض مقلق وجد الاحداث الدوحه من سنين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او ذاتي فتشوا ما خلا
اي حته فتش عشان القليل
ويسعد ما خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا
حته ما لقينا وحتى عربيه ذاتا يتحركوا بها
عشان يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في بنزين ما في
هناك طريقه نمرق من البلد عشان نمشي نفتش
الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا
يزال القليل منها الذي يعمل في الخرطوم
يعاني نقصا حادا في الادويه والمستلزمات
العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
وهذه صور نتابعها مباشره من العاصمه
الخرطوم وتظهر تصاعد اعمده الدخان من اكثر
من موقع كانت مصادر العربيه اكدت ان هناك
اشتباكات محدوده حدثت اليوم في صبيحه هذه
الهدنه السادسه التي تم تمديدها لمده 72
ساعه ونشاهد هذا الدخان الكثيف يتصاعد في
سماء العاصمه السودانيه قبل قليل ربما كنا
نتابع هذه الصوره لم تكن هذه الادخنه تخرج
يبدو ان هناك ربما اشتباكات حديثه
حدثت بالفعل
وكان الصحفي
ومراسل العربيه اكد لنا ان هناك تحليقا
للطائرات وان هناك مضادات ارضيه تصدت لهذا
التحليق واشتباكات محدوده وربما ما نشاهد
في هذه الصوره يؤكد بالفعل حدوث
انتهاكات لهذه الهدنه السادسه التي تم
اعلانها اليوم
طبعا الجيش السوداني كان وافق على تمديد
هذه الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه
واعلن بان موقف العمليات مستقره في
العاصمه الخرطوم وهادئ في جميع المناطق
وطبعا كان هناك ايضا بيان من قوات الدعم
السري اكدت بانها معنيه بشده بنجاح هذه
الهدنه لكن
حتى اليوم ونحن ندخل الاسبوع الثالث من
هذه الاشتباكات كل الهدن
تخللاتها خروقات وقصف جوي
ورد من قوات الدعم السريع وكل طرف يتهم
الاخر بانه مسؤول عن خرق هذه الهدنه لكن
مثلت هذه الهدن ربما
فسحه للكثير من المواطنين
للتنقل وربما التزود
بالحجيات الاساسيه التي تعينهم على الصمود
في ظل استمرار الاشتباكات وفي ظل الجهود
الحديثه التي تبذل على المستوى الداخلي
والمستوى الدولي والاقليمي لايجاد
هدنه ثابته وايضا ربما اساس
لبدء محادثات مباشره او غير مباشره بين
الطرفين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
توصل الى ربما وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
ومفاوضات ربما
توقف هذه الاشتباكات اذا من جديد صور
الدخان تتصاعد في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
في صبيحه
يوم الهدنه السادسه التي تم التوافق على
تنفيذها باتفاق المكونين العسكريين
اذا مراسل العربيه كان اكد لنا ان هناك
اشتباكات حدثت اليوم
وان خرقا الهدنه حدث وان تحليقا للطائرات
كان في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم وان قوات
الدعم السريع كانت ترد بالمضادات الارضيه
وكان هناك اشتباكات محدوده في اكثر من
منطقه
ومع استمرار المواجهات يواجه الكثير من
السودانيين مصائب حقيقيه في ممارسه حياتهم
اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال الدائر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع فيما يواجه عمال الاجره
اليوميه معاناه مع استمرار اشتباكات حيث
اختفت فرص العمل بسبب
فكره الطول الحرب بنيه شغل لكن معانا
والله بامانه كده يعني حكايه ظرف صعب جدا
جدا العمل متوقف
جاءت الحروب
بالنسبه لمحل انا اسكن ذليت 3000
بفضل اكون قاعد في بيتي مع اولادي
بس
حضر المبعوث الامريكي الخاصه السابق الى
القرن الافريقي جفري في لقاء مع صحيفه
الجارديان من اطاله امد الصراع في السودان
لانه سيفتح الباب امام جهات خارجيه تدعم
جنرال على حساب الاخر
الى منحا اخر وربما ينتهي بتدخل خارجي
لنصره احد جينيرالي النزاع ما ينذر بحرب
اهليه طويله الامد تقول صحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جافري
انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح لجهات
خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه ولذلك
يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لتقويد التحرك الخارجي تحذيرات لم تاتي من
فراغ على ما يبدو بعد ان كشف القائد
السابق لفاينر مرات جابيدول
للجاردنر موجوده في السودان منذ نهايه
العام 2017
مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
وافريقيا الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذر هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع حرب
اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما على
البلاد والعالم
محاسن حضاره العربيه
في متابعه لعمليه الاجلاء المستمره افاد
مراسل العربيه بوصولي سفينه حربيه امريكيه
تقل 308 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسيه قادمه من
السودان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي واضاف بان
الجده استقبلت 26 سفينه اجلاء قادمه من
السودان حتى الان بالاضافه الى 49 رحله
اجلاء جويه من بورتسودان وصلت الى جده تقل
اكثر من 2200 شخص كما ستغادر طائره عسكريه
هنديه من جده الى السودان
لاجلاء 140 شخصا
[موسيقى]
وعلى الحضور المصريه السودانيه يستمر
الالاف في النزوح في مصر السودانيون الذين
قرروا الفرار من النزاع عن طريق منفذ قصر
البري لتكون مدينه ابو سمبل اولى محطات
استقبالهم اهل المدينه حرصوا على تقديم
كافه انواع المساعده للناجحين نتابع
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من بعبر قسطنب البري الوجوه المرهقه من
عناء الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع
استقبال اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود
المصريه الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين
ما تيسر من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي
السودان قبل استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه
اسوان احنا طبعا لازم نقف جنب شقاءنا
السودانيين في الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا
عملنا المبادره دي مع شباب القريه عندنا
وحسينا ان احنا اهل البلد يعني يعني
الخدمه اللي قدموها لنا ما حسستني انه ليس
ما زلنا في السودان يعني بعض القادمين لا
يملكون الاموال اللازمه لاستكمال الرحله
احدى المجموعات النازحه توجهت الى وسط
المدينه لتفاجا برد فعل الاهالي الذين
قاموا بجمع المساعدات المطلوبه
والله انا يعني سم ده سمبل وانا
بقينا الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم
والله كل خير يعني احنا
وابناء وقفوا مع بعض وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونه للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
جاينا تعليمات من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء
تامين شامل سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو
لقينا برضو مساعدات من جهات تانيه بفضل
الله محدش مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعثاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنه الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
ويبقى معنا من مدينه ابو سمبل المصريه
مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان اهلا بك احمد
بدايه هل رسبت من خلال تواجدك
اي زياده في نسب واعداد النازحين القادمين
من السودان
من حيث ما اقف يعني في هذه المناطق كما
نرى الحافلات في هذا المرسى النيلي في
انتظار قدوم العبارات هذه العبارات التي
يعني تنسحب التي من المفترض انها تاتي على
مدار اليوم من قبل تاتي حامله للسودانيين
من خلال الحافلات بعد عبورهم من معبر قصته
للبري هناك محاوله لتقليل الكثافه التي
شاهدها المعبر الاخر الشهير هو معبر ارجين
وبالتالي هناك محاوله للتوازن ما بين من
ياتون من معبر ارجين ومعبر قسطل لاستيعاب
اكبر عدد ممكن دون ان يكون اي تكدس في كلا
المعبرين خلال
بعدما رايناه في معبر ارجين خلال الايام
الماضيه فيما يتعلق بسؤالك ابراهيم حول
الارقام يعني حتى الان ربما الملفت بان
وزاره الخارجيه المصريه كان في بيانها
اليومي تؤكد على عدد القادمين او النازحين
الذين دخلوا الحدود المصريه من المنافذ
المختلفه من مصريين وسودانيين واجانب في
الايام الماضيه او اليومين الماضيين بان
هناك من يدخلون فقط او من تم اجراءهم فقط
من المصريين الى مصر هذه الارقام ربما لم
تعد تذكر بالتحديد اعداد السودانيون الذين
دخلوا او السودانيين الذين دخلوا الى
الاراضي المصريه ولكن وفق اخر احصائيه
ربما بقى منذ يومين نحن نتحدث في حدود ما
بين ال4,000 والخمسه عشر الف سوداني قد
دخلوا الى مصر او تم اجلؤهم الى مصر منذ
بدايه الازمه ربما هذا الرقم يزيد خلال
المرحله المقبله مع علمناه الان بان معبر
ارجين يعني تم تقليل الاعداد الذي كانت
فيه في محاوله كما ذكرت لك لتقليل
التكدسمه الان التركيز على معبر قسطل
والذي ياتي منه الناس من مدينه وادي حلفا
القريبه وتم تغيير بعض الممرات من السودان
للوصول الى هذا المعبر طيب كيف هي ظروف
هؤلاء من اين ياتون والاسباب التي دفعتهم
هل هي فقط اسباب هروب من الحرب ام لاسباب
اخرى السعي وراء العلاج
لم شمل العائلات
وهل الجميع لديه قدره ربما او مكان يلجا
اليه في مصر
نعم يعني هناك تروح بالتاكيد هناك تفاوت
هناك من رايناهم وهم من يعني يملكون
الاموال ويبدو انهم مقتدرين اتجهوا على
الفور الى القاهره هناك من يملكون حتى
بيوت في القاهره راينا هذه الشريحه بالفعل
في الايام الاولى ولكن لا هذا ليس تعميما
هناك ايضا من يعني اتوا يعني ربما ليسوا
مقتدرين بالشكل الكافي ولكنهم قرروا ان
ياتوا الى مصر لي الاقامه عند بعض البيوت
عند بعض الاقارب عند بعض الاصدقاء لفتره
تامل ليشاهدوا ماذا سيحدث خلال المرحله
المقبله قبل ان يكون هناك عوده ايضا ربما
في الايام الاخيره راينا من الفئه الثالثه
او الشريحه الثالثه هناك بالفعل من ياتون
وهذا من رايتهم في الامس تحديدا يعني لا
يملكون قدرا كبيرا من المال لا يعرفون الى
اين يتجهون يعني خلال التقرير الذي اعددته
كان هناك يعني احد اصحاب الحافلات الذي
طلب منه ان ياتي في حافله فيها
من الامهات ومجموعات من الاطفال اولياء
الامور اما في الحروب او مسافرين او
مختفين عبروا الى مصر هنا وكان رايت في
التقرير تم جلبه جلب الكثير من الاموال
والطعام لهم من سكان ابو سمبل نفسه
وبالتالي هناك تفاوت وهناك تواجد للشرائح
الاجتماعيه المتنوعه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك
معنا مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان كنت معنا
من مدينه ابو سمبل المصريه ونتحول مباشره
لمتابعه الجهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء الى جده وينضم الينا من هناك
بمقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه مراسل العربيه
هانز فيان هاني هل تسمعني
نعم تحديدا من ميناء جده الاسلامي اهلا بك
واهلا بمشاهدين قناه العربيه
نحن نقوم
بنعم بمواكبه العربيه تقوم بمواكبه وصول
الاعداد الكبيره حقيقه سواء الايام
الماضيه او حتى التي سوف تصل اليوم ولكن
هذه المره لاول مره تصل على سفينه عسكريه
امريكيه قادمه من بورسودان وتحمل على
متنها
308 اشخاص من 16 جنسيه نتحدث هناك
من الرجال وكذلك
117 من النساء والسيدات وال 78 طفلا على
متن هذه السفينه وكما ذكرت انا من سته عشر
جنسيه 105 من الجنسيه الامريكيه
و15 من الجنسيه من السودان و 28 من
البريطانيه واحد عشر الماني وتسعه فرنسي
وتسعه
من السويد وسته من كندا وايضا من استراليا
خمسه وارترياء خمسه وايضا باقي الفلبين
وكذلك من سوريا شخص واحد اتى فقط والفلبين
واحد وايطاليا واحد والهند واحد وكذلك
تبقى فقط
هذا المجموع هو مجموع
318 اشخاص طبعا مع 380 اشخاص هناك ثلاث
حالات مصابه وتم تجهيزه من قبل اسعاف
ميناء جده الاسلامي الذي الان يقوم كادر
طبي بفحص حالتي حالته الصحيه وكذلك التاكد
من سلامتهم وسند الكاميرا تتجول في هذا
التجمع الذي
يشرف عليه حرس الحدود السعوديه مع جهاز
حكوميه وام وقطاعات ايضا حكوميه نتحدث عن
30 جهه حكوميه وامنيه وعسكريه هي موجوده
على هذا هنا على رصيف من جده الاسلامي
طبعا هذه واحده من مركبات الاسعاف المجهزه
والتي تم تجهيزها لاحدى الحالات الطبيه
وسوف نقوم الان
بمشاهده او ناخذ نحاول ناخذ بعض اللقاءات
مع رعايه الذين وصلوا للتو ناخذ لقاء مع
احد الاشخاص والحمد لله على السلامه الله
يسلمك
انا اصلا فرنسي من سودانيه
نعم
الخرطوم الرعب
والكوارث يعني بجد حتى الحروب الناس اللي
كانت بتتكلم عنها نحن شفناها شفنا الجثث
على الاراضي والروائح ولا كل الانتهاكات
اللي ممكن تتصورها في راسه
انت اول باول هنا على الركاب متاخره خاصه
عمليه بدات منذ اسبوع من قبل القوات
البحريه وسفن تجاريه وعسكريه
اجنبيهات يعني اذا كان
صراحه الناس تحب تنقذ الناس الابرياء
المفروض اللي جايكم من داخل الخرطوم
مباشره الطيران الحربي يكبس من كل العالم
ليش لانه في ضحايا تحت
يطلعوا من بيته انا شفته بعيني يعني هذا
الشيء في ناس الان عشان تطلع من بيوتها
عشان تقدر تحصل لقمه خبز
في كل مكان المشاكل الضرب النهب السلبي
العصابات التفلت الامني بكله يعني عجيب هل
الطريق امن من الخرطوم الى بورت سودان
والله يا اخي ما اقدر اقول لك امين وما
امن في طريق بتاع الجيش ومرات يمكن
الارتكازات تكون في ضرب تحصل مشاكل يعني
اذا صادق مهدد صراحه مهدد ما اقول لك في
امان ليش انه الجيش موجود في برضى
الاستكازات لكني اهجموا عليهم الدعم
السريع يختفوا الضحايا يكون المواطنين بما
انك انت الجنسيه الفرنسيه هل سوف تغادر
فرنسا ام سوف هناك ترتيب
طوالي فرنسا ان شاء الله طبعا تعرف ان
الاجراءات هنا في السعوديه خاصه في عمليات
الاجلاء تمنى تاشيرات
تاشيره سريعه طارئه حتى يتم مغادرتك اوضح
هذا لك الشيء
والله انا احب ارجع الفرس عايش فيها
وبلديه ثانيه يعني وطبعا السعوديه بلدنا
يعني وحبايبنا يعني انا احب انه ارجع اجي
ازور مكه وكذا ان شاء الله يعني الحمد لله
انه انا اتمنى انا الحمد لله اولادي بخير
الان في بلد الحبيب المصطفى صلى الله عليه
وسلم واتمنى انه العلوم المتحده
السعوديين اهل السعوديين اهم شيء
اليهود النصارى يفبسوا عليهم
الف عافيه شكرا لك شكرا اذا كان هذا احد
المواطنين الذي يح مل الجنسيه الفرنسيه
وهو وصل للتو الان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
وكذلك عدد من الرعايه وكما هنا ايضا عدد
من السفرات والقنصليات التي تقوم بانهاء
اجراءات رعاياها الذين وصلوا من سته عشر
جنسيه تفضل اذا تبعنا معك وصول هذه
السفينه ونزول من تم اجلائهم على متن
السفينه الامريكيه على الهواء مباشره انا
اشكرك هنصفيان كنت معنا من ميناء جده
الاسلامي شكرا جزيلا لك
يكافح عشرات الالاف الرعايه الاجانب
المغادره السودان في ظل استمرار القتال
حيث تجمعت حشود من المدنيين في الميناء
الذي يعد ملجا يتوجه اليه الكثير على امل
مغادره البلاد عن طريق البحر السودان عايش
في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
شمينا روحت الجسس ونحن جايين الخرطوم
الضرب الغزف يعني بجد السودان في حاله
تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبرهوا على
الكورنيش الناس بتنوم في الارض فرامل
اطفال مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين
هنا في مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير
يوفرون اصلا مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في
الارض ويعني اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي
كلنا جايين اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتيم من
الخرطوم
هذا وتتواصل عمليه لجاء رعايا الدول
الاجنبيه من السودان عن طريق عدد من
المنافذ ابرزها ميناء ومطار بورتسودان
وحسب احصائيات رسميه فان نحو 10,000 من
رعايه دول تم اجلائهم عبر البحر واكثر من
7000 عبر ميناء بورت سودان في وقت يستمر
فيه توافد الاف السوريين واليمنيين نحو
مدينه
لاستكمال اجراءات اجلاحهم نحو اليوم
العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه دول
العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق
السودان الى عدد من الدول في المنطقه اكثر
من نحو عشره الاف من رعايه دول الاجنبيه
تم اجلائهم خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
عبر ميناء بورتسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من
سته الاف غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
الى وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار
عمليات الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر
السوريه واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم في
انتظار استكمال اجراء مغادرتها للبلاد
احنا مو طالبين اكثر منه يتم اجلانه احنا
مطالبين من اي بلد يقعدوا في ناس او
يصرفهم شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر امن من هنا
الى الحدود السوريه وشكرا البعض تفضل
البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل والحصر هنا
واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه على توفير
دور مؤقته لاوائهم في ظل ظروف يحاول الجهد
الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه بورسودان تخفيف
وطاتها على العائلات والنساء والاطفال
الموجودين حاليا بشرق السودان نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث مدينه
بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
[موسيقى]
الان نتوقف مع ابرز الاخبار الدوليه بعد
ان دعا مسؤول اوكراني المدنيين الى البقاء
في الملاجئ مع اطلاق سفارات الانذار لنحو
ثلاث ساعات من ساعات الصباح الاولى اكد
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه ان دفاعاتهم
اسقطت 15 صاروخ الروسيه من اصلي ثمانيه
عشر موضحا ان كل الصواريخ الروسيه التي
حاولت استهداف كييف تم التصدي لها ولا
اصابات وقعت اثرها حسب المعلومات الاوليه
كما افادت وسائل الاعلام اوكرانيه بوقوع
انفجارات اخرى في دينبرو تو فيسك ومناطق
في سومه
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استهداف عده مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش
الاوكراني في دنيتك واكد المتحدث باسم
الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه قامت
بشن غارات على ثلاثه مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش
الاوكراني مضيفا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تكبدت خسائر بشريه وصلت الى 60 شخصا
في فرنسا تستعد النقابات لاحياء يوم
تاريخي لعيد العمال اذ تتوقع نزول مايصل
الى مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى شوارع
لمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
وقال الامين العامل الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل انهم يتوقعون مشاركه مئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين موضحا ان النقابات
اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف انحاء البلاد
لاحياء عيد الاول مما يوم من جهتها تتوقع
السلطات نزول نحو
60000 متظاهر من ضمنهم ما بين 80 الى 100
الف في باريس وحدها كما اكدت ان 12 الف
عنصر من الشرطه سينتشرون لضمان الامن
وانضم الينا من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه
حسين قنيبر اهلا بك حسين بدايه كيف تتوزع
التحركات اليوم والاستعدادات التي قامت
بها الحكومه وقوات الامن لمواجهتها
اهلا بك ابراهيم اولا النقابات تريد لتحرك
اليوم الاحتجاجي وهو الثالث عشر منذ منتصف
شهر يناير تريده عرضا للقوه على الارض
ستتوزع التظاهرات والمواكب الثلاثه التي
تحدثت عنها في مقدمه الخبر ستتوزع على مدن
كبرى ومتوسطه بالاضافه الى باريس ستكون
هناك تحركات في اليوم وكذلك في
ومارسيليا وتولوز ونيس وكان وليل
وستراسبور ونونت وبوردو
وكذلك في كلارنس قبل دقائق من الان بدات
التحركات في كل من اليوم ومارسيليا
وستبدا التظاهر المركزيه في العاصمه عند
الساعه الثانيه من بعد الظهر بالتوقيت
المحلي النقابات الرئيسيه ستشارك كلها في
هذه التحركات التي لا يقتصر الاحتجاج لن
يقتصر الاحتجاج خلالها على رفع سن التقاعد
من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما بل سيشمل الاحتجاج
على التضخم وغلاء الاسعار الذي بات ملموسا
يوميا في كل تفاصيل شراء المواد الاساسيه
من مواد غذائيه ووقود واسعار فواتير الغاز
والكهرباء ابراهيم لكن ما الذي يميز هذا
اليوم الثالث عشر عن باقي الايام هذا ليس
اليوم الاول الذي تحدث فيه احتجاجات
وبالتالي ما الرساله التي تريد النقابات
ايصالها اليوم
الرساله مفادها انه ورغم صدور قرار المجلس
الدستوري الذي اعتبر ان البنود الرئيسيه
في رفع قانون سن التقاعد مطابقه لدستور
فان التحرك لن ينتهي ثم ان المخاوف كبيره
لدى الاستخبارات الداخليه التي اشارت في
مذكره داخليه لها الى احتمال وجود مجموعات
شغب من بين اعضائها البالغ عددهم ما بين
الف والفين من سيقوم بتحطيم واجهات محل
تجاريه والقيام باعمال شغب وعرقله سلميه
التظاهرات عاده عناصر الشغب والمجموعات
التخريبيه كما تسميها وزاره الداخليه
يتراوح عدد اعضائها بين 2400 هذه المره
سيتراوح عدد اعضائها في تحرك اليوم ما بين
1000 و2000 توقعت مذكره الاستخبارات
الداخليه ان تكون اعمال الشراب
واعتبر ان معظم بنود يعني هذا القانون هي
دستوريه فماذا ستستفيد النقابات من كل هذه
التحركات على الارض
طبعا النقابات تعرف انا اعداد المتظاهرين
تتناقص من تظاهره الى اخرى لكنها تعتبر
انه لا يمكن حكم شعب ضد هذا الشعب لا يمكن
حكم بلد ضد شعبه كما قالت الامينه العامه
لنقابه الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل ونقابه
ايضا المعروفه بمرونتها وحواورها المنتظم
مع الحكومه قالت انها ستذهب الى الحوار مع
هذه الحكومه ولكن وفق شروط من بينها اعاده
النظر بالرواتب وبظروف العمل الاحزاب
السياسيه انتقدت بشده قرار المجلس
الدستوري زعيم اقصى اليسار جوني اعتبر ان
هذا المجلس اظهر انه حريص على حاجات
الملكيه الرئاسيه اكثر من حرصه على حاجات
الشعب السيد لنفسه والملكيه الرئاسيه هي
عباره يستخدمها زعيم اقصى اليسار للاشاره
الى ان ماكرون يحكم كمالك وهو ما تعتبره
الحكومه نوعا من الذر للرماد في العيون
ومن العبارات المسيئه لمقام الرئاسه ايضا
الحزب الاشتراكي على لسان الرجل الاول فيه
اوليفيا فور اعتبر ان راي المجلس الدستوري
لا يعني ان قانون رفع سن التقاعد هو قرار
عادل ولا يعني ابدا اننا سنوقف محاربات
هذا القانون اي قانون رفع سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 كما قال الرجل الاول في
الحزب الاشتراكي
ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لك مدير مكتب العربيه
في باريس
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل طفل لم
يكمل الثامن عشره او 18 ربيعا برصاص
القوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب
اريحا ووفقه وزاره الصحه فان عدد الاصابات
بلغ سته اشخاص ثلاثه منهم في حاله خطره
بعد اندلاع مواجهات اثر اقتحام المخيم
ومحاصرته ياتي هذا مع مواصله القوات
الاسرائيليه لليوم العاشر تواليا اغلاق
مداخل ومخارج مدينه اريحا من عده جهات
تستضيف الاردن اجتماعا لوزراء خارجيات كل
من السعوديه والعراق ومصر وسوريا بهدف
التوصل لحل سياسي للازمه في دمشق وبحسب
الناطق الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الاردنيه سنان المجالي فان مبادره الاردن
تهدف لبناء اتصالات عربيه مع الحكومه
السوريه ضمن الجهود الراميه لانهاء ازمه
سوريا وياتي هذا اللقاء استكمالا للاجتماع
التشاوري في جده في منتصف ابريل الماضي
وكذلك قبيل القمه العربيه المزمع عقدها في
الرياض في التاسع عشر الجاري
اعلنا الرئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان مقتل
الزعيم المفترض لتنظيم داعش في سوريا خلال
عمليه نفذتها الاستخبارات التركيه وقال
اردوغان ان بلاده ستواصل عملها في محاربه
التنظيمات الارهابيه دون استثناء
مجادله اود ان اشارك الجمهور معلومات
جديده خلال هذا اللقاء هناك التطور يظهر
معركه نصار ضد التنظيمات الارهابيه
الاستخبارات التركيه كانت تتعقب منذ زمن
طويل من يسمى زعيم داعش المعروف بابو حسين
القرشي وهذه هي المره الاولى التي اعلن
فيها هذا الخبر خبر القضاء على هذا الشخص
خلال عمليه نفذها جهاز الاستخبارات التركي
في سوريا وسنواصل عملنا لمحاربه المنظمات
الارهابيه دون استثناء
وثقت مقاطع فيديو مشاهد الاعصار الذي ضرب
اولاد فلوريدا الامريكيه وتسبب بانقطاع
الكهرباء عن حوالي 4000 شخص وكان اكثر
المقاطع لفتا للانتباه ما نقله شهود عيان
قالوا ان احدى المركبات انقلبت وتحطمت على
الرصيف وتطاير ركامها امامهم
اوميجا
هذه هي الساعه الاخباريه انتهت لكن
التغطيه مستمره خصوصا لاخبار السودان على
راس الساعه مع الزميل نايف الاحمري تفضلوا
بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات